the al-aqsa mosque which you see behind
me is the third holiest site in Islam
but unlike the first two it's been under
Israel's occupation since 1967 and
Israel completely controls both who gets
to enter and pray there recently
Palestinians have been protesting the
installation of metal detectors at the
gates of the compound Palestinians
refused to enter the compound under the
new restrictions but after hearing
reports of Jewish settlers being allowed
inside which is forbidden according to
rabbinical rulings we decided to go
inside and when we did we found it
largely deserted permeant azide Solly na
jayate Alina Mandic Manor ll in G
hastily left thrown in the middle by the
health medicine
remember that reporter I look at India
for temperature many Palestinians many
Muslims who normally would enter here
are refusing to enter because of those
metal detectors when you ask them
basically why are you choosing not to go
inside they say it's not a choice we
can't enter this mosque just like you
wouldn't enter your home if someone were
to set up metal detectors there now it's
not a lot for me changer they want to
shake me when I am going inside all my
life is inside how you can stop me from
injuring inside something not acceptable
at all heavy in a 40-minute sorry I did
not imagine I would not be an ideal but
we're bad liar bajalia ad Israel claims
that East Jerusalem including the
historic old city is part of its capital
but almost all countries around the
world refused to recognize Israel's
sovereignty over this area which is
predominantly Palestinian and yet on the
ground there's no denying who has the
power
Israel runs the services controls the
security and doesn't allow any official
Palestinian Authority to operate there
and that includes the other Aqsa Mosque
Israel maintains strict restrictions on
the movement of Palestinians from the
West Bank in Gaza
here to Jerusalem and they generally
have a policy of denying many Muslim
visitors from entering
[Music]
we want the justice without the freedom
we want you to be deal as a human being
with us who are not they did you were
just like even less than animal adding
to the tension is the fact that managers
this compound known to Muslims as had a
machete to be the site of the Temple
Mount they believe that this is the
location of an ancient Jewish temple and
many religious groups have long desired
to rebuild that temple where this mosque
stands as I always do put the more
realities on the ground as know very
well that the most is added loyal after
much pressure from Palestinians Israel
swapped the metal detectors with
security cameras hoping to pacify
further protests the definition you know
I love socks off Oh Betty Bruin tough
let let they should be fair a lot to bet
on it should double it a little but the
soup how come the local shit you said
that this is a really emotional time but
what do you actually feel
we feel lonely we feel that all the
words this picky about justice about
your humanity but you know one of them
are caring really about you justice or
humanity people outside supposed to
understand that you are under occupation
we are in the 21 century and this is
happening too now this race is what is
happening here just because we are
policing this entire area is under
Israeli occupation according to
international law and Israel styles
itself as the state of the Jewish people
so you can understand why many
Palestinians and Muslims around the
world fear that this holy site is under
threat constant Israeli excavations and
archaeological digs in this area haven't
helped them justify these claims and
neither have events like when the former
Israeli Prime Minister Ariel Sharon
visited the compound Israel denies it
has any intention to harm the mosque or
change what it refers to is the status
quo the vast majority of Palestinians
and Muslims are already excluded from
visiting before they even get to
Jerusalem
it's not only just Holly for the Muslims
also it's a place that we add the
Jerusalem people Muslims and the
Christians that we grow up inside
they're depressed so inconsiderate part
from our life anabolics anima see he
knows it better in Monty so you're a
Christian
why does al-aqsa matter to you if this
book will put the seven locks oho
and when of hooks myrrh food when I was
my Nana grabbin measured locks on a
journey and her ox will mislead me who
do you see as pressure mounts on Israel
to ease tensions with Palestinians even
more security measures were added at the
al-aqsa mosque compound of course this
not only adds to the anger among
Palestinians but exacerbates the
conflict itself and makes it all the
more likely that clashes will continue
I'm a sucker ordinarily love penis in
Zulu we're all so we so good
[Music]